you know i thought you had one of the
best tweets i've ever seen
uh and i'm gonna misquote it but it's
when they did the first stimulus for
this
and your tweet was something like i
guess they did have the money
for health care was it for health care
or for something else
what was the quote well in my case it
was uh it was for
universal basic income yeah because you
know i love that stuff but i guess they
did have the money for
your universal basic income the whole
time right and that's what we learned
which is
all these things that they don't want to
do let's say forgive
some student debt or to end
mass incarceration whatever it is that
we always did have the money
we always do to take care of health care
we have the money to give
you know a lot of cash to casinos for
losing money over the last few months or
or two we have the billions for that
but we've given millions i meant
trillions yeah we
have fixed schools for the country we
could have free college
uh you know for a lot of people in this
country so
sadly where my head goes is
you know when you think about it a lot
of this is
a scam you know it's a scam it is
siphoning off money
to people who don't need it and even
when the economy collapses
you know the richest among us they make
money in that even donald trump said he
loved when the economy crashed in 2008
he made a lot of money
buying things up when it was cheap the
stock market is at all time highs
uh you know on in many respects like the
winner take all economies is getting
more extreme
but you're 100 right judd that the work
has to
um has to kick into high gear as soon as
the new president's in place in 2021 and
we don't have
that much time like we have to go huge
and big to try to
rejuvenate revitalize hundreds of
thousands of communities around the
country
because if we fail in this and it's one
reason why you you do need a
somewhat um uh
unified legislative branch like you hope
that the democrats and you know like
have enough of a critical mass to get
some real work done get some real bills
passed
but we have to do the work over the next
number of years or else
like that this wave does come crashing
back the other way
you know it's like in a way like i feel
like americans
donald trump was like a giant fu to the
system just like screw it like get the
narcissistic reality tv star in there
drain the swamp um i believe that
joe will win and then we'll have a
chance to do the work
uh and we just need everyone to actually
uh get on board with like a more active
invigorated
effort to revitalize the country that
emanates from the federal government
and i know there are a lot of people who
aren't like huge fans of the government
um like taking a leadership role in a
lot of these things but like we have no
choice i mean you're talking about
like a multi-trillion dollar uh effort
that's needed to
do a lot of the things you just named
you know like uh
overhaul our our totally immoral system
of incarceration
invest in infrastructure and renewable
energy new schools
like you name it like we should be doing
it because we're short
millions and millions of jobs and the
folks who are in their houses right now
figuring out how they're going to make
ends meet
like it's it's heartbreaking like we we
just uh
we just failed i mean like our
government has been
out of touch with the people for so long
and i think that's one reason why
um someone like trump won uh and now we
have to come back from it
absolutely and i think that on some
level after uh
obama there were a lot of people who
said well you were in for eight years
it didn't touch me it didn't get to me
and
obviously you know that administration
would say
you know we didn't control uh yeah there
was mitch mcconnell saying hey
let's like obstruct everything in sight
and so they obstructed
everything and so you know one point of
view is they accomplished an enormous
amount
for having that type of obstruction
but it is up to the country to give the
president
the power by controlling the senate and
the congress i mean if you want anything
to happen
you you have to control both to have you
know a real sea
change with the environment i mean you
know here's the scariest part of the
pandemic
what we're learning is that a certain
percentage of the country
is kind of crazy like they won't wear
masks
they're not long-term thinkers you know
to solve the climate issue
i mean if you get someone to wear a mask
how are you going to get somebody to
have solar panels
how are you going to have somebody to
make a choice to switch what kind of car
they drive
i mean it requires hundreds of
sacrifices
for everybody to save the planet and
we're
as a country we're not long-term
thinkers people seem to feel like i want
to be as happy as i can be today
i don't want anything to to
inconvenience me
and i will fight you to the death for
that but
if as a country and as a world we're not
in it together
if we're not all making sacrifices if
we're not all trying to lift each other
up
uh we will we definitely will not
survive
i mean when you look at the world and
you know how they
uh have reduced their coving cases and
you look at our country where everyone
feels like they deserve everything all
the time and we can't do it
even today we can't do it well
that can't do spirit is
what will have our cities underwater
in 50 years and that's the saddest part
i mean donald trump clearly didn't ask
anything of the country he could have he
could have gotten on deep and said
as of today here's what i know every one
of you i don't care if you're in the
middle of the woods and no one's around
wear masks
and we're going to be out of this and
we're going to save a lot of lives
and we're going to get back to work and
he won't say it and he encourages
a certain kind of defiant independence
which will prevent us from solving covet
it'll prevent us from solving the next
pandemic which we also think is coming
is coming yes and prevent us from
solving the the climate crisis
which we're in the center of right now
and no one wants to
talk about it well i think it's one
reason why you and yours are so
important
judd is because you're one of the
preeminent storytellers of this time
and like we need ways to communicate
some of these ideas to
folks in america who you know
aren't in one camp or another and i
thought your movie king of staten island
actually like helped make like really
important
points that any american would
understand and be excited about around
sacrifice and loyalty like you know from
pete's family which was somewhat
biographical like a lot of it's around
the fire department in
uh staten island uh and you know if you
think about you know like who's pro
fireman i feel like that's everybody
well i i think in a way what the one
reason why i wanted the movie to come
out now
was because i thought this is what we're
talking about
that in a way there's a spirit to the
firefighting community
that is selfless you know there are
people
uh and we see them in all different
businesses now
but if you just think about firefighters
they get up every day
they're gonna get a call they're gonna
put themselves in a dangerous situation
to help you out and they're trying to be
there
for the people they work with you know
they're trying to be in the best shape
of their lives so they can save you
so they can save themselves so they can
save the people that they work with
and it's all about service right
and i think that you know the
republicans
mock service they mock the idea
theory they're all about service in
theory you know they're all all about
like uh
yeah the army and people yeah they like
to talk about the cops in the army but
when you really get down
to it you know they're really more about
power they're they're not about
firefighters because firefighters
are saying your life is important
and i'm going to spend my life trying to
make your life better
and in a way that's what every citizen
in the country
we're all firefighters now at least we
are because
because the country's on fire absolutely
and
and so it shouldn't be america first or
make america great
it shouldn't be that when people don't
want to get killed by the cops that you
call them marxists
that's not what it's about you know
that's a that's a signal like oh no
they're marxist
it's about that we all need to help each
other we all need to lift each other up
that's why it's so powerful when you see
uh you know those mothers the other
night in portland
yeah stand up to this secret police
force well it says everything there
you know those are people clearly there
are people relying on them and they
think it's worth
putting themselves in physical danger to
call out the madness and to try to stop
it
and we will not survive as a species
without
we are interconnected you know you could
say make america great but
we have to be in communication with
every country in the world to solve
these problems
yeah yeah i mean how are you going to
fight the next pandemic
if you're not in contact with the
governments of other parts of the the
world who are probably going to be
seeing it first
yeah we're quitting the w.h.o
we're getting out of the paris climate
accords
we you know this is the moment where we
should be trying to figure out how to
make
all of these connections work better
and that's what i hope happens with with
joe biden thank you for listening in i
hope you enjoyed this conversation if
you did
please do subscribe to yang speaks and
click on notifications so we can let you
know
every time we have a new episode
[Music]
you